well after a tough year of cobit
learning schools across the valley
continue to celebrate
their 2021 graduates somerset academy
holding a special ceremony tonight to
honor their students
as they send them out into the world
sasha loftus joining us now live from
craig ranch regional park where the
ceremony is just getting started sasha
denise it is set to start any moment now
you can see those stands are filled
families are ready
and just really thrilled to celebrate
these 2021 graduates
in person today now just over 100
students are donning those caps and
gowns with their families in attendance
and a few other special guests today
like many other schools this is the
first time
all of the 2021 seniors have been able
to gather together like this in months
or even more than a year
we spoke with the school's principal
earlier today she says it's really
refreshing to see everyone really come
together like this
we've gone back and forth on the
ceremony we've you know talked about
holding it in smaller
sections of the graduating class but to
be able to bring everyone together
is just it's bringing us back to normal
it's great for our graduates it's great
for our families and so we're just
really excited to be here
masks are today for everyone even though
this ceremony is
outdoors now any guests in attendance
here again have to wear those masks
there are also a few special guests set
to attend
this includes the nellis air force base
color guard and carnell johnson is
also expected to arrive he sings the
national anthem for the golden knights
game so
this really special event for everyone
here for those graduates for their
families
as they celebrate in person here at this
park at this
event reporting live today sasha loftis
8 news now